good morning Hank it's Sunday so the
Yeti and I are beginning this Gigantor
home renovation part of which is to
replace these moldy basement walls with
like non moldy basement walls and when
the contractor came in to talk to us
about it he was like look I recommend
destroying the wall on your own I mean
it takes a professional to build a wall
but anybody can demolish a wall and now
Hank a week later I feel like I can say
with authority and pride that if anyone
can demolish a wall I can do something
that no one can do fail at demolishing a
wall and so today Hank I'm going to
share my unique talent with you I am
going to teach you how not to demolish a
wall in six easy steps step one the
octopus
so name my first strategy to try to tear
down the wall this was pre holes by the
way was to throw myself against it I did
this once before actually I threw myself
against the wall to find out if I was an
octopus because you know octopi stick to
walls but people don't and when I did it
that first time I felt the wall shake a
little so the first thing I tried was
the octopus yeah still not an octopus so
that didn't work then I moved on to step
2 calling former Soviet leader Mikhail
Gorbachev
oh hi mr. Gorbachev tear down that wall
and he was like stole stole Yanni Gavin
ooh pong whiskey you know and then of
course I remember he doesn't speak
English and plus he lives in Russia so
he like totally expensive to find
Indiana just to tear down my basement
wall and so I moved on to step three
calling dad dad said I needed a crowbar
but I felt like crow bars are like
handguns you know I understand that I
have a constitutional right to own a
crowbar but I don't really feel like I
need one unless I'm a career criminal
but he eventually convinced me to go out
and buy a crowbar whereupon I commenced
with step four attempting to use a
crowbar which way like that for about an
hour and a half then I moved on to step
getting really angry which is where the
holes in the wall that you see come into
play
basically Hank I got really mad and I
started to hit the wall which I don't
mean metaphorically holed smash then I
did that until I felt sleepy whereupon
it took a nap and then when I woke up I
moved on to step 6 which if you're going
to not demolish a wall you want to save
until the very end of your experience
step 6 is checking to make sure there is
no active electrical wiring in the
places where you are willy-nilly
throwing your steel crowbar which as it
turns out there is so that's how you
don't demolish a wall you do the octopus
you call Mikhail Gorbachev you call your
dad you get a crowbar you go bonkers you
take a nap you wake up from the nap
check for electrical wiring and then
declare yourself a proud and epic fail
Oh home renovation you have begun so
auspiciously Hank you'll see me on
Tuesday but will you see the wall only
time will tell
so hey I think when you get a crowbar
you're supposed to want to like smash
stuff with it but that wasn't my initial
reaction my first reaction was that I
wanted to treat it as a cane and kind of
do it dance like this it didn't - do do
do do do do do do